hey there it's great to have you back
today we're thrilled to share our top
seven interactive websites where Cutting
Edge UI is reshaping how creators and
users connect in the digital space these
designs don't just look great they
Captivate engage and leave a lasting
impression transforming the way we
experience the web so let's dive into
these inspiring picks and Spark your
creativity website number one defont era
the defr aray website offers a
captivating visually driven experience
that reflects the Brand's focus on
innovative business solutions and
digital transformation the design is
Sleek and modern incorporating 3D
elements and smooth animations the
website stands out with its interactive
components such as Crystal rendered
visuals and dynamic scroll animations
creating an immersive and engaging
experience they position themselves as a
brand and business accelerator helping
companies Envision and execute new
strategies in branding distribution and
retail for the modern era the website
effectively uses storytelling and data
visualization to highlight their
services targeting startups and
businesses looking for creative and
cuttingedge solutions with a minimal yet
bold color palette featuring shades of
purple and teal and typography that
combines elegance and Clarity the
website presents their message in a
professional yet Innovative way it's a
great example of how design and
Technology can work together to convey
complex ideas in an engaging format this
website has received recognition for its
creativity earning an honorable mention
on Awards reflecting its excellence in
design usability and Innovation overall
it's an inspiring blend of functionality
and creativity aimed at businesses
looking to thrive in a new digital
landscape website number two David
heckoff David heck off's portfolio
website is a visually stunning example
of how modern web Technologies like
webgl and 3js can be used to create an
engaging and interactive experience the
site showcases heckoff skills as a
creative developer featuring smooth
animations bold typography and vibrant
colors that highlight his expertise in
webgl and
reactjs the website starts with a
memorable landing page animation that
smoothly transitions into a 3D portfolio
presentation demonstrating his work
through a mix of interactive elements
and creative visuals a standout feature
is the about main section where a
hologram likee design adds a futuristic
touch the site's minimalistic yet
playful design combined with a seamless
user experience reflects his ability to
merge creativity with technical Prof
efficiency it's a great example of how
personal portfolios can be both
professional and Visually captivating
website number three feton the fony
website is a vibrant interactive
platform designed to empower Fitness
enthusiasts of all levels it promotes an
AI powered mobile app that tailor
personalized workout plans offering a
range of exercises that can be done at
the gym home or Outdoors the website
uses Sleek modern Design Elements such
as scroll triggered animations and micro
interactions creating the highly
engaging in Dynamic user experience fony
stands out by offering customizable
workout routines allowing users to
select exercises based on their goals
such as increasing muscle size losing
weight or improving endurance whether
you prefer strength training body weight
exercises or cross trining the platform
provides detailed workout plans that
cater to individual preferences the
design is userfriendly and Visually
appealing with bold typography and a
limited color palette that keeps the
focus on content and interaction the
website also integrates well with
Fitness tracking tools like Apple watch
ensuring users can stay motivated and
monitor their progress effortlessly This
Modern approach to Fitness aligns well
with feton mission to provide accessible
and efficient workout Solutions making
it a goto resource for Fitness beginners
and athletes alike website number four
Virgin Galactic the Virgin Galactic
website offers a visually stunning and
immersive experience that aligns with
the company's mission of pioneering
commercial space travel the moment you
land on the site you're greeted with
death taking visuals including
interactive 3D models and videos that
capture the excitement of space
exploration the Sleek modern design
effortlessly guides users through the
company's Vision achievements and future
goals highlighting the incredible
technological innovations behind their
space flights a standout feature is the
seamless storytelling which takes
visitors on a journey from the Earth's
atmosphere to the edge of space
reflecting the sense of awe and wonder
associated with space travel the website
emphasizes the exclusivity of the
experience with details on the
spacecraft Astronaut training and the
transformative overview effect that many
space Travelers experience it's not just
about space flight Virgin Galactic seeks
to create a meaningful shift in
perspective for those lucky enough to
journey into space the website balances
high-tech sophistication with
userfriendly navigation making it easy
to explore everything from technical
specs of their spacecraft to the
astronauts stories it also promotes
their commitment to sustainability and
innovation in Aerospace technology
reflecting virgin galactic's broader
goals of making space more accessible
while minimizing environmental impact
before we move forward we're considering
something exciting launching our private
Community for you a dedicated space for
designers to connect share insights get
feedback and learn from each other we'd
love to hear your thoughts would you be
interested in joining and where would
you prefer this community to be hosted
let us know in the comments website
number five fairm pipe the FM pipe
website takes an Innovative approach to
presenting a traditionally industrial
product galvanized steel fences and
Gates instead of relying on standard
product photos the site incorporates
detailed 3D models to showcase the
products in a more engaging way this
allows users to explore the intricate
details of the steel frames from
multiple angles setting fipe apart from
competitors the seamless integration of
3D animations clean design and subtle
scroll triggered effects keeps users
engaged while navigating through the
site the website also focuses on
showcasing ferm pipes unique production
technology which utilizes folded seams
instead of welding this distinction is
highlighted in a visually captivating
manner through a mix of animations and
storytelling the choice of green is the
primary color for the site reflects the
company's branding tied to the painted
steel frames they manufacture FM Pip's
website has received significant
recognition winning multiple awards for
its innovative and user-friendly design
proving that even industrial websites
can be visually appealing while
effectively communicating their
technical expertise website number six
Organo the Organo website presents a
visually striking and engaging
experience reflecting the brands Focus
On Wellness through their seos and
bladder products the design is clean and
modern utilizing Dynamic 3D elements to
draw visitors in right from the start
this immersive style is enhanced by
seamless Transitions and interactive
elements that guide users smoothly
through the website making the browsing
experience feel fluid and captivating
Organo emphasizes the health benefits of
its Flagship products including improved
immunity energy support and respiratory
Health while maintaining a minimalist
aesthetic that keeps the focus on its
core message the blend of highquality
visuals and detailed product
descriptions gives the site a balance
between informative content and user
engagement ensuring a pleasant journey
for users exploring the brands offerings
overall the website is a perfect mix of
visually appealing design and clear
messaging which both educates and
inspires visitors to explore the
benefits of their products further it's
a great example of how storytelling
through design can elevate a a brand
experience last but not least website
number seven Apple airpods Pro the
airpods Pro 2 page on Apple's website
offers a smooth and Visually captivating
experience that seamlessly Blends
Cutting Edge product information with
elegant design the transitions between
sections are fluid guiding the user
effortlessly from one feature to the
next enhancing the overall navigation
the use of subtle animations and scroll
triggered effects adds to the modern
high-tech feel creating an immersive
experience the design is minimalist and
clean with highquality visuals of the
airpods Pro 2 and its mag safe charging
case prominently displayed in multiple
angles each product feature is
highlighted with interactive elements
and clear easy to understand
descriptions the overall layout of the
page is intuitive making it easy for
users to engage with the content without
feeling overwhelmed the website also
includes interactive components like
augmented reality to view the product in
3D on mobile devices which adds a layer
of personalization and engagement this
thoughtful integration of design and
Technology ensures that users get a
detailed yet seamless exploration of the
product feeling inspired whether you're
just starting out or looking to improve
your design skills we're here to help
you on your creative Journey the gap
between where you are now and where you
want to be is filled with exciting
opportunities to learn and grow and
we've got just the right tools to help
you along the way join over 10,000
designers marketers and developers who
have already taken their design game to
the next level with with our uiux
Playbook packed with over 100 actionable
tips tricks and strategies this guide
will give you everything you need to
create beautiful functional designs and
here's a little bonus use promo code I
love ui4 for a 40% discount and get
started today we'd love to hear your
thoughts drop a comment below to let us
know which website from the video
inspired you the most and feel free to
share any other impressive sites you
think we should feature in part two keep
pushing your creativity and I'll see you
in the next one have a fantastic day